company Adolfo Ibarra I am an entrepreneur
here in this business
in tell me where your
business is located it is located at 15-13 west
great world corner with Martin Luther
King well see a little bit of how the
pandemic has obviously brought many
changes to your business
tell me a few things  that you have
changed this price has changed something you
could say a bit of intimidation
among the staff among the people
I did not know what it is based on when this ends
how to handle the situation
and you here as an entrepreneur here
you are tell me a little about the new
things  that you have always implemented
every day you hear that there are new
regulations, new changes in the
health center and control of the governor,
how are you putting yourself on the sidelines, well,
I am taking the sidelines, you are
having toilets for clients
since this started before it was  liquid
is now gel since this social maintenance began to see it
the stickers the
protector for the cashiers
everything  That is why we have been keeping
the staff there, demanding gloves and
masks and continually washing their
hands, especially with the control of
all hygiene, what one already knows has
become a bit difficult, this is if it is
something that came out of the routine  from one to
change to another another different routine
because you have to check the temperatures of
the employees since they come to
work as they come,
that has been extracting a little towards
another level of life to another
different direction something that was not there one
was used to would not reach
work and after that what you have
is a normal unit and this is really
a critical change for one of the
employees, as they have accepted these new
rules at first they were resistant to
not wanting to do that but
as time went by and
they began to realize the situation they
had to accept and I also
became a little stricter with them
because that was good for them and for
some who did not  they appreciate it is they not
only they but all the others
we also know that there are many businesses
that are being affected right now
many tell me that every day
something new is thrown at them a new rule a
new precaution and sometimes this
becomes a little bit a little bit  a little
too much for them not so for you
how do you feel right now with all this
you feel that you are getting all the
information you need and you feel a
little behind maybe
not knowing the language as well or not knowing how to
use the computer like other businesses
you  Do you think that this is affecting you
or is it affecting you a bit? Yes, it is
affecting me a bit because this, like
access to the computer, is not formally my thing,
what I am most focused on is working
and moving the business forward in
actually I don't have much time to
be involved in computers and all that and
if I have been delaying part of that
information that the truth is I don't have
that the other time  The information that is
required, such as about
the pandemic procedures,
is already being provided to me by the
president of the corporation, but it would
help you a lot if there were organizations
that wanted to make that change and it would
get closer to you and tell you about
these new changes, of course  yes, it
would be very convenient and that there was
someone who was interested in supporting us
in terms of the changes and the
processes to follow according to what
is happening with the gang
and again remember us because it
is very important for you to maintain your
business  open and it and follow all the
rules well it is important for us
because well the income we have for
the well-being of our families
including all the
workers and well apart also the
clients as we have given them a
service well they also have to eat
that is why the chamber of commerce
says that they are ready to
help them sign president of the
latin chamber of commerce
we are daily working
very hard very hard
on certain things education speaking with
our community
explaining that we have to wear masks
today more than ever if they are not going to
close us down and there are not going to be jobs there is not going to
be anything like that  we have to start with the
masks also in the chamber we have
resources we have
several programs to have access to
capital to money to access to education
how to do it a little better we have
all that in the Latin chamber of commerce
because we love our community very much